but even with a higher money I just some
of those companies I didn't feel like I
wanted to be in business with and
neither did more serious made the most
sense with the amount of Freedom we
would get Capital we would get the time
the deal was and what we had to turn
over in the small window we had so you
know I I love the narratives that have
been put out there I laugh at them too
I'm a big I'm on Reddit all the time as
well like I see everything not just and
my other free only fans content of
course not well that's that's not my
algorithm right
um my lack of my lack of responding does
not make something true and I know me
saying that does not matter to the
internet but I don't care is there like
so the only Reddit thing I jumped into
was the no jumper Reddit oh that's
that's a that's spicy it's a nasty Place
well because I so I was hit up by Adam
to do the first show without a d t rail
this was the the day that he fired Lush
on camera yeah he hits me up and he's
like hey man you're down to do the show
tomorrow and I was like yeah I've been
on the show before so I was like yeah
okay whatever no idea you know then I
see oh this will fire Lush on camera
today so I call A.D and I'm like hey man
uh what's going on over there he's like
bro I'm about to [__] quit
and I was like what the [__] I was like
what am I walking into he's like dude
just do it just do it you know I was
like all right so I do it and everyone's
assuming like I'm the replacement yeah
and I'm like dude I'm not the
replacement but they were eating me
alive on Reddit
it was hilarious of course I mean of
course they're gonna do that I'm shocked
they didn't pause Adam more on that
because in the Lush and A.D thing there
was also the white supremacist thing was
going on at that time there was like the
joke about the slave owners yeah there
was a lot of [__] so like throwing me or
you is like the replacement probably
wasn't the best move but and I feel and
I feel for Adam not on that side but I
feel I feel for him as far as like [__]
just one day a whole operation is moving
and then you lose that and then and then
the next I have empathy for Adam me too
me too for sure I told him I said dude
you're [__] mentally
strong brother because during that time
there was everybody was like [__] no
jumper and then that dude rolled up
there on the live stream with that old
ass [__] that he'd already put the bed
and rehashed that and it was just like
but that's that's the tough [__] outside
of everything that stuff with the
internet to some degree when people have
been waiting for your downfall they're
waiting they will make small things into
the largest thing ever and even when
things pass the next time a small thing
will happen that's why I did everything
I could not understand like Joe grilling
him so bad because I was like dude
really I I thought it was appropriate I
just did I just was like
I just feel like if if people wanted to
like rehash old [__] like like you know
like if somebody wanted to be a dick
there's a lot of old Joe Budden [__]
that is like hearsay or for sure that
people could just stir up if they ever
wanted you know what I mean I I I didn't
it was on whatever the radio yeah yeah
um no I did listen to it I thought uh I
didn't think
Joe was harsh on him I thought it was
appropriate if you were going to have
Adam on your show at that time you gotta
address you and Joe would look even
crazier if you're trying to get the guy
that all the attention is on right now
for clicks and then you don't and then
you don't and then you feed your
softballs you look [__] nuts so I
didn't think there but also why I and
I'm a hypocrite a lot I try not to grill
people on a lot of stuff because to your
point like not to the degree of like
racism or something but we all have our
[__] so and we're all gonna have our
moments especially in this world I'm not
one of those people in the media that
protects each other right I'm in the
middle there there's some people that
are like we're all media we can't post
bad things about us because like we
don't want to get to War I think I think
that's corny as [__] for sure but also
going super in on someone for small
mistakes if they some things are
inexcusable for sure
I'm not big on just doing that and maybe
that's probably not good in the content
game for me to feel that way I I should
do that for Content purposes but I just
I have my own [__] too like
yeah I'm just not gonna [__] scream
at someone when they make mistake I've
done it before don't get me wrong but at
this point in my life you feel like
you've grown
just in perspective perspective is
important
uh I just saw you I didn't know you had
a daughter until I saw the video you
just posted yes I mean I didn't even
send you the album by accident so that's
right it's on the ultrasound no so uh
how old is your daughter
a little over three months well
congratulations thank you has that
changed your life drastically I mean
obviously besides like waking up but has
it like some people I mean listen I have
a son that's 18 I had him when I was
well he's about to be 18. I had him when
I was 18. so I had him when I was 18.
but that you know it was so long ago I
couldn't like I just was like trying not
to be poor and be homeless you know
understandable so like I don't know like
like what did that what does that do for
you like mentally
um it's weird I used to look at like
parents when they would say like
memeable
like corny basic [__] about kids I'm
like all right I'm sure it's like we get
it yeah I get it but I it makes me stop
it like reminds me of Joy just like just
looking at her makes me stop where I
never would have stopped like that's the
surface level of how it's changed my
life it's like little moments
I lacked little moments in my life until
her of course she's the biggest moment
but but
created little moments in my life that I
never had before and like makes me
reobserve
everything like I sound like the corny
parent now that I'm saying like I'm I'm
walking her in a stroller looking at her
and she's looking up at trees and I'm
like [__] this is amazing remember
trees remember those
and she is just amazed by [__] so I
don't know if it's selfish to say this
but it also has allowed me to like be
reintroduced to so much things within
these three months of watching her
observe other [__] that I've had around
me forever right like it makes me even
appreciate
[__] a bit more like just her curiosity
of everything makes me feel weird